the ivy league is in a state of collapse
after the presidents of upen and Harvard
denied that calls for genocide
constituted harassment on campus Miss
Migel at Penn does calling for the
genocide of Jews violate Penn's rules or
code of conduct yes or
no if the speech turns into conduct it
can be harassment yes I am asking
specifically calling for the genocide of
Jews
does that constitute bullying or
harassment if it is directed and severe
or pervasive it is harassment so the
answer is yes it is a context dependent
decision congresswoman it's a context
dependent decision that's your testimony
today calling for the genocide of Jews
is depending upon the context that is
not bullying or harassment this is the
easiest question to answer yes Miss
Mill so is your test that you will not
answer yes if it uh is if the speech
becomes if the speech becomes conduct it
can be harassment now right after that
the president of Harvard says the same
thing oh yes it's context it's all about
context you just don't you don't
understand the context of the genocide
since then the Penn president has
already resigned now calls for the
Harvard president president gay are
escalating especially in light of a
recent discovery that she plagiarized
large parts of her doctoral dissertation
that is a serious academic crime but the
only reason that it's coming up now is
because people are already calling on
her to resign and that's all because of
this Congressional
testimony if you have been paying
attention to politics in recent years
that testimony did not surprise you you
already knew that the universities and
especially perhaps the ivy league have
gone completely
insane but most people were not aware
most people don't pay very close
attention to politics that Congressional
hearing last week was
terrific for this reason it was pathetic
it was sad it was depressing that that's
how far education has fallen but it was
terrific in that it did to the ivy
league what the covid lockdowns did to K
through2 education that is it forced
people to see just how far American
education has fallen the silver signing
of the covid lockdowns was that it led
to an historic spike in homeschooling
people pulling their kids out of school
now that they finally discovered what
those kids were being taught there the
same might now be true of the
universities up to and including the ivy
league which for decades by the way has
been the Beating Heart of the left's
political power that might be the most
effective Congressional hearing and
quite some time I'm Michael nolles this
is the Michael nlls
Show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode's
brought to you by good ranchers head on
over to goodranchers.com subsscribe
today with code nolles KW has to claim
your free Limited stock Christmas ham
before it sells
out you won't be surprised hear this but
Dr fouchy don't need no religion Dr
fouchy in a recent interview explained
why he has no need for our omnipotent
and Omni benevolent God that of course
is because fouchi views himself as that
very God we'll get to that in just a
moment first though I don't want to move
off the Harvard story too quickly
because a lot of people thought the
Harvard president would be protected the
Harvard president president gay checks
at least a couple intersectional boxes
very hard to ouster they got rid of the
pen lady she held on for a little bit
she's just a white lady so it's a little
easier to get rid of her will the
Harvard president who is a black woman
will will the Harvard president be
forced to resign or can the
intersectional game of victimhood
protect the Harvard
president plagiarism is a big deal the
ivy league does not really care about
any crimes any any things that were
traditionally understood to be crimes or
transgressions in Academia they have a
bunch of non sense departments they have
rampant grade inflation kids are
constantly boozing and having sex all
the time usually encouraged by
subsidized by the university none of
that matters I know in some schools you
can be arrested you can be reprimanded
for drinking and partying and messing
around that is not true in the ivy
league when you enter into a school like
Harvard or Yale or Princeton you are
often told that those transgressions
they're treated as health problems
they're not they're not something that
you would be punished for it's it's nuts
they're bigger party schools in many
cases than the big state schools that
make the top list of the party
schools plagiarism is the only thing
that can really get you in trouble you
can commit physical assault you you are
less likely to get in trouble at these
schools than than
plagiarism and the Harvard president has
just been caught red-handed by Chris
rufo one of the great journalists of our
age as well as by uh uh Chris brunette
both found out that this woman
plagiarized a lot of her dissertation
it's not even just a word or two so This
Woman's dissertation was called taking
charge black electoral success and the
redefinition of American
policies uh she was uh she is now
accused of lifting the work quote nearly
verbatim from Lawrence Bobo and Franklin
Gilliam in their paper race
sociopolitical participation and black
empowerment the Harvard policy is very
clear they say when you paraphrase your
task is to distill the sources ideas in
your own words the Harvard guidelines go
on it is not enough to change a few
words here and there and leave the rest
instead you must completely restate the
ideas in the passage in your own words
if your own language is too close to the
original then you are plagiarizing even
if you do provide a citation my favorite
example of plagiarism here is when
President gay cites well doesn't cite
she lifts material from but does not
site Carol Swain my friend of many years
now a conservative
uh academic who was run out of Princeton
run out of Vanderbilt because she's
right-wing she's a a very accomplished
uh political scientist apparently the
president of Harvard uh even held her in
such esteem that she lifted Carol
Swain's work without citing her I'm
happy at least that when the Harvard
president plagiarizes she's willing to
plagiarize conservatives too not just
liberals uh she she appears to have
taken an entire appendix in the dtation
uh from Gary King in his book a solution
to the ecological interference problem I
think she's out I think it doesn't
matter how many intersectional boxes she
ticks she's transgressed she's gone too
far the donors don't like this it's just
like the parents finding out what K
through 12 is teaching their kids during
covid all of a sudden the kids are
staying home learning goes online the
parents get a peek into the classroom
they say what on Earth are you doing and
they start electing Republicans and they
start attacking the school board
meetings and they start pulling their
kids out in home schooling I think that
Scandal that was caused by by parents
seeing what was actually being taught in
K through 12 that Scandal is being
repeated now at the highest levels of
higher education really really great
stuff now speaking of degradation on
full
display if you happen to be in Iowa this
week you can catch a satanic
altar uh put up on display at the Iowa
state capital this was put up by the
satanic temple the co-founder of the the
satanic temple says this is a symbol of
the satanists right to religious
freedom of course Satanism is not
entitled to any rights whatsoever and
the founding fathers certainly wouldn't
have thought so and no no one even the
great Defenders of religious freedom not
so long ago would have ever defended
this but this this is now what religious
freedom is taken to mean that you can
have a a symbol of baffet or the devil
on display and you have a right to that
in a government building the founder of
the satanic temple says we're going to
really relish the opportunity to be
represented in a public forum we don't
have a church on every street corner uh
my feeling is that if people don't like
our display in public forums they don't
have to engage with them they don't have
to view them okay if you're a normal
person you probably have a problem with
this now some some of you might not some
of you might say oh whatever it's dumb
it's silly the satanic temple there are
just a bunch of edgy Reddit tier
atheists anyway who cares what they want
to do I don't like it I don't want my
country to
exalt satanic symbols I think that's bad
I don't want shrines to Satan in my
government buildings I think that's a
bad thing to do and doesn't speak very
well of our country and I want it out
and I want to ban it and I I'm this
would not be a new ban this would be
reinstating a ban that existed for the
entire history of our country until appr
approximately five minutes ago I think
that would be good I think that would be
normal and American and right now you
might look at that and say well it's
okay it doesn't really matter I don't
like it it seems wrong but hey you know
religious freedom
right so then you got to ask the
question if if you know this is wrong
but the the premises that you have about
religion and politics lead you to saying
that this is fine how do you reconcile
those things one of them is you it can't
simultaneously be good and
bad so which is it how do you
reconcile your natural opposition to
Satan statues in our state capitals with
religion
Freedom you can
either say yeah Bring it on Bring on the
satanic altars let's put them in all our
our state capitals let's bring them to
Washington DC you can either say that
most of you probably won't think that or
you can totally throw out religious
freedom which some of you might want to
do but it's probably not very practical
in
America or there is a third
option the third option is you can
circumscribe what religious freedom
means
not merely on your own preferences or
you know a naked political power grab
but you can set limits on what religious
freedom
means through tradition informed by
reason you don't need to just pluck it
out of thin air or have it be a matter
of your own preferences you can say look
here's what religious freedom is always
meant in America it's never
included opposition to God it's never
included it's it's included broad
religious toleration for different
people who worship God in different ways
but it's never included opposition to
God or outright denial of God that was
just really never part of it and so
we're not going to allow that no
satanists no atheist altars none of that
you you can we can have a broad amount
of religious toleration without saying
that you're you have a freedom from
religion or freedom to to worship the
devil in the state
capital that's what you can do Libs
should love this Libs love saying that
no right is absolute until they want
their Satan statues in the state capital
then all of a sudden the rights are
absolute your your First Amendment right
is not absolute when you want to talk on
a college campus and you're a
conservative your first amendment
right's not absolute when you want
access to the Public Square on social
media to to say your conservative points
of view your Second Amendment right oh
that's never absolute you're you're only
allowed to have a musket you're this
right you're that right but you know the
the the supposed right never really
articulated in American jurist Prudence
or political philosophy to have a Satan
statue that that that's the one that is
AB absolute no of course of course not
of course not I don't think that the
Satan statue falls under any serious
conception of Freedom or religion
religion is a habit of virtue that
inclines the will to give to God what he
deserves but even if you do even if
you're a little confused on what freedom
and religion mean how about you how
about we just Avail ourselves of history
and reason and tradition that's what
tradition is about it's not about just
blindly giving up your own ability to
think and and have your own opinions
it's just allowing your opinion to be
informed by
every other smart person who ever lived
don't you think it maybe there's a
chance that every other smart human
being who ever lived for all of
history uh might be able to teach you
something that you haven't just figured
all of it out better than all of the
other smart people well there it is
welcome to traditionalism There It Is
Well you're a conservative wonderful
wonderful to have you we got to talk
about these things when you when you
want to talk you got to check out P talk
right now go to P talk.com P talk has
you covered for the holidays with a free
Moto g5g phone no gimmicks or trade in
necessary just sign up for Pure talks
unlimited talk unlimited text and 15
gigs of data you can get all of this for
just 35 bucks and you will get the Moto
G 5G phone for free you need to move
fast because these phones are almost
gone so if your current phone is on life
support upgrade for free with pure talk
the new Moto g5g phone boasts a twod day
battery life an exceptional quad pixel
camera and a whole lot more P talk gives
you America's most Dependable 5G Network
at half the price so make the switch
today go to Pure Talk /ns kwes to get
this exclusive offer and select the plan
that is right for your family Pure Talk
gives you America's most Dependable 5G
Network at half the price make the
switch today that is p talk.com nkw to
claim your free Moto g5g phone with a
qualifying plan Pure Talk put simply is
smarter wireless head on over there
right now these guys have been great
supported the show they give you the
best network out there head on over to
pure talk today unfortunately there's a
state represent reprentative in Iowa
representative John dunwell who seems
like he means well but he you can see
him grappling with this conflict between
uh we don't want to worship the devil in
our government buildings but you know we
got religious freedom and he he doesn't
seem to figure it out so he has this
very very long post about it on social
media and he vacillates he says well as
a follower of Christ I think this but as
a state representative I think this but
as a follower of Christ I think this but
as a and it's so long I didn't even read
the whole thing
because he's just twisting himself into
knots the the first error is to think
that you can actually separate yourself
into little compartments you can't you
can recognize that uh you have certain
duties and certain circumstances but to
suggest that you are multiple different
people and you can totally divorce your
moral views from your political life is
just completely insane politics is how
we all get along together and all laws
legisl morality so here's what he says
he says my response to the Satan statute
as a follow of Christ my response as a
state representative my observations and
respones an Iowan state representative
and
Pastor as a follower of Christ I
certainly find a display from the
Satanic Temple objectionable it stands
in direct opposition to my faith and
would be classified as
evil not a new experience for me or my
family the word of God continually warns
about the dangers in our world In
fairness many other religions or
non-religious people have the same
perspective about Christianity put a
pause right there
yeah they do they're
wrong they're
wrong you you say x is good Y is
evil other people say Y is good X is
evil one of you is right and you can't
just shrug your shoulders one of you has
to be right because you're going to live
together and you're going to enshrine
good things in the law and you're going
to prohibit bad things in the law too
that's what law does so you can't just
you say well you know look I my perspect
right where does your perspective come
from is it completely uninformed it's
just it's just a a reflex of your mind a
a uh a contortion a gesticulation it's
not informed by reason no it's informed
by reason you think it's true and So you
you're going to broadly follow that yeah
it's a good idea says my observation as
an Iowa and a state representative I
don't want the state value valuating and
making determinations about religions
I'm Guided by the First Amendment of the
US
Constitution first of all are you are
you I don't know that's the first
amendment was never understood to
enshrine Satanism so and I'm not sure
that you are you're enshrined by a
liberal revisionist view of the First
Amendment but even here's a more basic
question to to representative dunwell
and I don't mean to single him out a lot
of people think it like
this are you are you a Christian first
or a liberal first I mean a lowercase L
liberal I mean the classical liberal I
mean whatever the good whatever good
kind of liberal you can think of what
what are you first are you a Christian
or that do you serve God first or do you
serve
some political ideology called
liberalism which is it when they come
into
conflict man cannot serve two masters
which is it not hard for me I talk to
Christians I talked to religious Jews I
talk to Muslims I talk there's broad
agreement I think think among people on
broadly how to serve God in public life
and how to have a good
Society I don't think the same can be
said of liberal look what liberalism's
done it's it's alienated people from
their society it's it's led to a kind of
skepticism where even a guy who calls
himself a Christian pastor says well I
don't know some people think
Christianity is evil so the state needs
to lay off it I mean the man this is a
politician very sad very very sad
the I've heard liberalism described a
liberal is one who who cannot take his
own side in an argument Bill Buckley
said it very well he said skepticism has
utility only when it leads to conviction
so what's the conviction what do we
believe what is it what do you actually
believe what does Dr fouchi actually
belied Dr fouchi just gave an interview
because he can't help himself and he was
asked about his views on religion here's
his take there's dog in Chapel where
Chris and I were that's you married yeah
yeah yeah it's beautiful yeah it's
really nice do you still go there do you
you don't practice anymore do you I
don't no
why ah a number of complicated reasons
go on we have a whole
Corridor first of all I I think my own
personal ethics on life are I think
enough to keep me going on the right
path and I think that the there are
enough negative aspects about the the
organizational Church M uh that you were
very well aware of I I'm not against it
I identify myself as a Catholic I was
raised I was baptized I was confirmed I
was married in the church my children
were baptized in the church but as far
as practicing it it seems almost like a
proformer thing that I don't really need
to do he identifies in a way he is
Catholic he's baptized he said his kids
are baptized thank God that's great he
says but I don't need it well then how
do you identif you got to practice it
don't
you what he has articulated here will be
interpreted by many people as being so
enlightened so modern so thoughtful he
says look listen here you think I'm
going to do with some some guy in a in a
robe and a collar tells me to do that's
ridiculous nah I follow my own ethics
and that is sufficient to put me on the
right path that that is not a a new view
even though it's many people consider it
a new view it's a very old view that's
called the pelagian heresy which
suggests that human nature is good and
therefore we're uh we can save ourselves
we can we are not in constant need of
God's grace which is what he's saying
he's saying I don't need to Avail I
don't need to Avail myself of the
sacraments humble myself before God
because I am God well that's that's what
he's implying but he's he's he's almost
stating it explicitly saying I can I can
live a good life on my own I don't need
no
God it's an old idea and old ideas
always seem new bad old ideas always
seem new when they creep back up and
they creep back up for all of human
history he's not alone though there's
something in him that's drawing him to
say well actually I should baptize my
kids actually I should get married in a
church and he can't quite articulate why
that is because because he has this this
uh bigotry against the church which says
well it's really dumb and crazy and I'm
really smart and Brilliant I wouldn't
fall for that superstition mean
meanwhile fouchy tells us that we put a
hanky on our face we're going to stop
getting Airborne illnesses you you want
to talk about Superstition stand 6 feet
away not 5 and 1/2 ft and then you won't
catch the Airborne illness take take
this this vaccine that contrary to all
data I insist will stop you from
Catching or spreading a virus oh whoopsy
Daisy all my data well all of my
predictions were wrong oh yeah but you
know that church has been around for
2,000 years that keeps enduring yeah
that that's crazy right we clearly he he
has some attraction to it still he just
can't get over his own Pride this is a
man who has multiple portraits of
himself in front of his desk so that he
can look at himself all day not uh not
great people need to look for something
higher they need to look for a higher
Bond right now go to higher bond.com if
you are single or know someone who's
single you've probably seen or heard
about all the insane dating apps out
there what if I told you there were a
dating app that actually cares about
your morals and biblical values well now
there is with a new dating app called a
higher Bond higher bond is a new
Christian dating app built to be safer
less stressful and more Christ centered
higher bond is completely different from
anything else out there there's no
addictive swiping the focus is truly on
quality over quantity and it's designed
to form lasting marriages higher bond is
a Christian company that is veteran
owned by a husband and wife looking to
change the way Christian singles meet
online it's no secret that big tech
companies are against other companies
like higher bond in fact big tech
companies would would highlight the word
Christian on on the ad copy for higher
Bond they say yeah this this is
violative you can't include that in your
ads our society and our country need
what hbond is doing if you're single you
need to check out HB bond.com sign up
before December 31st get three months of
highbond Premium absolutely free that is
higher bond.com today if you've seen the
number one streaming comedy in America
lady Ballers then you might have seen us
mention the creation of a woman's razor
by Jeremy in case you missed it check it
out ah man looking smooth man you guys
weren't kidding these Jeremy razors are
amazing and did you know that Jeremy now
offers a razor specially designed for
women and don't forget about Jeremy's
shampoo and conditioner they keep our
hair silky and
smooth well that wasn't just a scene in
a movie despite the despite the delivery
of that the product is really great
we're introducing all new women's razors
and personal care line by Jeremy because
Jeremy's razors is all about equal
opportunity to shop the woke free
economy the sugar and the spice and the
everything nice in life deserve the same
quality woke free blades as men Jeremy
will make another razor when God makes
another gender there are two genders two
razors plus we have a new line of
personal care products for our better
halves including moisturizing shave
cream lotion body wash and deodorant
ladies go to Jeremy raisers docomo and
personal care products
today speaking of sacraments there is a
very prominent liberal streamer
commentator I don't name who goes by the
name Destiny I don't know his real name
I I have not really watched much of his
stuff I think I was supposed to debate
him at one point perhaps we'll do that
into the future
uh Destiny from what I gather has been
in an open marriage and has
defended uh his wife he and his wife
sleeping with other people uh our buddy
Sovereign bra over here was on the
whatever podcast and warned him that
this would likely not end well God
forbid this happens will it be fun if
this open relationship ends up causing
things to fall apart down the line if
one of you guys finds yourself in a uh
an entanglement so to speak with with on
with somebody who you might find a
deeper connection with than the other
person like if that causes the
relationship to to fall apart that
probably wouldn't be very fun no it
would be horrible and it would be sad do
you guys have a high degree of
confidence that your marriage will last
for decades I mean I married her without
a prenup so I hope so okay or else this
motherfucker's going to be he married
her without a prenup good on him
actually that's that's great not good on
him to sleep around with other people
and to let his wife sleep around with
other people uh he explains why why he
decided to start doing that on the same
show best sexual partners that I've had
in my life were all the people that I
were in the long-term relationships with
like on a one night stand like it's hard
to know like when I things even that fun
sexually depending on what you're
looking for I can agree that the longer
you're with somebody the better sex gets
so why is she not enough why is she not
enough it's I mean like it's kind of
like asking it's kind of like if you've
got like a close friend but then you've
got other friends like well why is that
one friend not enough because in life
sometimes variety is fun sometimes I
want to be with a girl that's Hispanic
or Asian sometimes I want to be with
somebody that is friendship I didn't say
marriage was a friendship but marriage
to me isn't just about my a lot of
aspects to my marriage that I share with
my wife that's really unique to my wife
that I don't share with other people my
is just not one of those
things that's not good that's not good
uh anyway you know how the story ends
even if you've never heard of any of
these people uh they're getting divorced
very sad uh not going to make fun of him
a lot of conservatives seem to be making
fun of this guy because his wife is
leaving him I think it's very sad and I
hope they patch it up and just get back
together and stop sleeping with other
people I think hope that's good I'm
entirely opposed to divorce and so it
would be good if they just did that I
don't know the story she left him for
some guy or whatever um the reason I
even mention the
story is is not even really about
marriage or relationships it's just a
broader point about human behavior which
is
that things that have always been true
are very likely still true
today and that seems like a really
simple point but people get confused
about it things that have always been
true for all of human history
everywhere probably didn't just
radically change in the last five or 10
years really like we've pretended that
they've changed in the last five or 10
years but they probably
haven't because they've always been
true everywhere on Earth there might be
a reason
why things have always been a certain
way everywhere
forever and we might not have the
ability through sheer tyranny of will to
just upend or totally reverse them and
invert them
overnight it it has always been the case
that if you and your wife sleep with
other people your marriage is going to
be weaker and you're more likely to get
divorced that was true yesterday it's
true today it's going to be true
tomorrow it has always been the case
that marriage involves sexual difference
we forgot that one isn't that crazy we
just that was true for all of history
and then like eight years ago we just
totally upended that one and pretended
that it doesn't but obviously it does
and and you you see so much more
confusion about marriage he says
marriage is kind of like you and your
buddies no it's not it actually isn't
like you and your buddies marriage is
different well you you like having
multiple friends that's true I do like
having multiple friends though having a
really good friend is kind of rare
actually you don't have hundred really
good friends you have a handful at at
most most people are lucky if they have
one really good
friend but yet yes you can have multiple
friends friends are different than
spouses spouses for instance have to be
of the opposite sex you have to
complement one another physically and
probably spiritually and intellectually
too uh it uh marriage is ordered toward
producing children it's not true of
friendships maybe some friendships but
shouldn't be that's that's that's
something else that would distinguish it
it's uh for forming the basic political
unit of society which is the family is
distinct from other webs and types of
networks just different that's always
been
true it's going to be
true it's going to be true tomorrow so
in the case of this streamer guy I hope
they hope they patch it up but for all
of you take it as a warning the the gods
of the copy book headings come back
speaking of weird sex stuff do you
remember there was that candidate who
was running for Virginia House of
delegates and she was a blonde
lady and she was discovered to have been
a porn actress online and not just a
porn actress 10 or 20 years ago I think
she had still been doing it even while
she was running for office or just
before she was running I think she may
have even been raising money for the
campaign by doing the the sex act on the
internet well Politico has a postmortem
of her campaign she lost by the way and
the headline
is her online sex life was exposed she
lost her election now she's speaking out
here's the subit Susanna Gibson's
campaign was rocked when an opponent
exposed her private Digital Life to the
public she won't be the last okay hold
on I missed something I the headline I
agree with her online sex life was
exposed she lost her election now she's
speaking out that's true what is what is
the private Digital Life
here this woman exposed herself it's not
that her opponent exposed her Prim she
exposed herself and performed sex acts
for the public on the internet which is
forever for
money and then her opponent noticed that
her opponent her opponent's big crime
here is not doxing her it's not exposing
her it's not revealing some private sin
her her opponent's big crime here is
noticing a public act and then telling
the public about it and she ran for
public office how am I I I do feel
somewhat bad for this woman because
she I don't know what has happened in
her life and in her mind to lead her to
the point where she would do that and
then think it's a good idea to run for
office doing that
but
I I I I don't blame her opponent for
calling this to the attention of the
public it's a public matter I think the
expectation of privacy has just gotten
completely insane and in part that's
because we think that what we do on the
internet has no moral value or broadly
we think that what we do on the internet
will have no consequences it's just fake
it's not Twitter isn't real you know it
isn't forget about the sex stuff for a
second even the way we speak to people
on the internet the way that we present
ourselves we just think oh it doesn't
matter it's just fake it's anonymous I'm
behind a computer screen I'll talk to
people however I well there's no there's
no consequence for it there is the the
libs have always been really into
privacy because they want to do bad
things and they can't really justify the
bad things on their own merits so they
have to justify the bad things on a
supposed right to privacy that doesn't
actually exist in the Constitution that
had to be invented by liberal jurists in
the middle to latter part of the 20th
century and now here they're trying to
say you have you you have an expectation
to privacy when you're performing
pornography on the internet for the
public just exposes the whole thing you
don't you don't have any privacy
including on the
internet I just think conservatives like
privacy a little bit because we know
that the liberal regime is out to get us
and they're going to send the Gestapo to
our house if we're a little too pro-life
or if we're a little too Catholic or you
know that's already been happening so I
understand from a credential matter as a
credential matter why we would want a
little more privacy uh but in principle
there's no reason to have the kind of
insane supposed privacy protections that
we have today we're the we're social
creatures and when when you totally
remove yourself you know the darkest
corner of your house away from all
people where you think no prying eyes
are watching things can go really bad
actually I want to we might want a
little bit less privacy now I said
forget about weird sex stuff for a
second now we're going to switch back to
it and also talk about the doj because
the doj has just threatened to sue
Tennessee if Tennessee does not reduce
penalty
for hookers who know that they have HIV
passing it on to
clients this is a December 1st release
it just came out the doj said that
Tennessee's decades old prostitution law
is is wrong and that they will sue over
it because this
law subjects people who have HIV or Aids
to quote harsher criminal penalties
solely because of their HIV status so
they're saying that by punishing people
for knowingly giving HIV to other people
you're actually violating the Americans
with Disabilities Act because HIV is a
disability and so hookers who are
selling their bodies for sex usually
against the law uh if if you punish the
ones who uh knowingly give their clients
AIDS more harshly you're actually
attacking the poor disabled community
and this is the this is the cherry on
top the the doj sent out this release on
world AIDS day so the and they
acknowledged it they said today's
announcement comes on world AIDS day an
International Day dedicated to raising
awareness of the AIDS pandemic so on
world AIDS day the Biden doj attacks a
state for trying to reduce the spread of
AIDS I want to make sense of that and I
actually I think I can make sense of
that they think that the best way to
commemorate World AIDS day is to protect
aids to to protect AIDS and to grow the
AIDS Community we oh yes we want we want
to make sure that the AIDS Community
continues to thrive we want more and
more people to catch AIDS happy world
AIDS day no that's not what world AIDS
day is supposed to be about guys it's
supposed to be about shrinking the
number of people who have AIDS by
preventing the transmission of the
virus uh how does the law work the law
raises uh prostitution from a
misdemeanor to a felony when when a
person intentionally give someone AIDS
okay is this is the lib's priority this
is it we're on the brink of World War
III on on two fronts right now in
Eastern Europe and in the Middle East
we've got a completely wide open border
absolute record high mass migration a
fenel crisis killing a ton of Americans
the economy is extremely shaky right now
inflation had gone through the roof
during the first part of Biden's tenure
and what the Biden doj is focused on is
making sure that mean old Tennessee
doesn't
stop doesn't doesn't try to stop the
hookers with AIDS from giving people
AIDS that's priority number one of
course of course it
is a good rule of thumb here is that on
any issue that involves wrongdoing and
victims any issue that
involves crime
the libs will always take the side of
the criminals the libs will always be
concerned with protecting the supposed
rights of criminals over actual victims
every time every time including here
this one is particularly ridiculous
especially because they made the
announcement on world AIDS day doesn't
matter there is I think no exception to
that
rule it's a rule of thumb you want more
crime you vote for the Democrats you
want more crime you vote for the
Liberals you want less crime you vote
for the conservatives
more than anybody I think I I try to
point out the complexities and Nuance
Nuance in politics not in this case that
is all totally reliable you know what
else is totally reliable good ranchers
right now go to goodranchers.com use
code NES what do green eggs and your
Christmas dinner have in common they
both need a ham to be complete not just
any ham but a spiral cut Heritage pork
Masterpiece from good ranchers that's
the kind of ham that'll steal the show
at your family gathering guess what you
get it for free with any good ranchers
subscription that's whopping $99 value
that you get for free in your first
order you know what I had last night
Juicy delicious chicken you know where I
get my chicken and my steak and all my
meat basically is from good ranchers and
it is just the best stuff out there the
price is unbelievable you get free bees
like this $99 ham it's just completely
insane simply subscribe to any box you
will get your totally free Christmas ham
included in any order the subscription
is amazing get 25 bucks off every order
a free gift in every third box and free
shipping on express delivery the best
part is knowing exactly where your meat
comes from and that is through a local
American Farm here's the Scoop
goodranchers.com subscribe today with
code nolles to claim your free Limited
stock Christmas ham before they sell out
act fast this offer won't last forever
order before December 11th for
guaranteed delivery by Christmas head on
over to goodranchers.com use code nkw
when you subscribe to get your free 10
pound Christmas ham don't settle for the
old holiday Fair elevate your Feast with
good ranchers this year good ranchers
American meat delivered my favorite
comment yesterday is from the late
Arthur Morgan who says Michael it's not
liberalism it's
leftism
respectfully is liberalism too it I
understand those are different things
because there's left-wing liberalism and
there's right-wing liberalism which is
some libertarianism or sometimes
Classical liberalism but my criticism is
of the whole thing I think liberalism
broadly not to paint with too broad a
brush some of my best friends are
classical liberals but but liberalism
itself is a big problem because it
undermines the any ability to make
conclusions about reality and about the
truth that's why we say Liberals are the
people who can't take their own side in
an argument it it creates a radical
skepticism it makes a false idol of
openness and
neutrality it can't defend itself
against other ideologies and and
aggressors it it it displays
indifference between good and evil and
right and wrong and truth and false
falsity and as it has affected the
universities the universities have have
given up on their main mission which is
to pursue the truth as it has affected
polies the polies have given up on their
main mission which is to do good and
avoid evil it's just is wrong also it's
based on false premises The View man
primarily as an individual and that
shrug their shoulders when it comes to
truth and says we can't really know
anything at all but I think we can and I
think man is a social creature and a
political animal and I think liberalism
is bad some versions are are better than
others but they're all just kind of
wrong now speaking of the
libs Joe Biden and the
Congress have spent S5 billion dollar on
electrical vehicle
charging this started two years ago they
they spent 7 A5 billion
how many electric vehicle Chargers do
you think have been built now 2 years
later with that 7 and half billion you
guessed it none whatsoever the 2021
infrastructure investment and jobs act
included 7 and half Bill to build a half
million public charging stations across
the
country under this program states can
qualify for as much as 80% of the cost
to build these Chargers and to get them
up and running 80% and
still none of them have been built the
money's gone but none of them have been
built political
reported not one single charger was
operational I think they only broke
ground on a handful of
them green projects the the
environmentalist projects are generally
a scam it's just payoff cindra you
remember cylindra probably not because
the the political scandals just cycle so
quickly it's a way for Libs to funnel
money to their friends but the projects
don't really get built they they
certainly don't meet the requirements
that we need or the promises that were
made to to fund the
projects it's just a scam and it's a
scam that plays on people's increasingly
Pagan religious views where we worship
Mother Earth and they they tell you that
if you don't give $7 half billion dollar
to build the charging stations for
Teslas that are also subsidized by the
government that uh the sun monster is
going to eat us all and kill all of our
families and and eat up the Delta smelt
and the polar bears and then none of
that actually happen none of it happens
the the sun monster doesn't kill us the
polar bears are still here the Delta
smelter still here and we don't have any
electric charging stations it's just a
scam now speaking of Libs Mitt
Romney Mitt Romney is weighing in the
2012 Republican Presidential nominee is
weighing in on who he thinks can beat
his arch nemesis Donald Trump and it's
kind of sad for Romney because Trump is
clearly Romney's arch nemesis but Romney
is not Trump's arch
nemesis so like that Meme you know
you're I think about you all day long
and and you know the the other person
says I never I never even think about
you Romney is was just Driven Crazy by
hatred of trump he's he didn't support
the Republican ticket in 2016 he's he's
no longer practically a
republican which means that when he
endorses a candidate who is a republican
it doesn't actually reflect well on the
candidate it's not even a candidate's
fault it's just now well I'll cut to the
chase now Nikki Haley has to deal with
the baggage of a Romney endorsement I'm
not going to be uh endorsing president
Trump obviously I've made that very
clear um look Chris Christie has done a
terrific job so far I think his being in
the race has kept Donald Trump from
coming the to the debates because I
think Donald Trump recognized if he went
to the debate with Chris Christie Chris
Christie would reveal him for what he
was and and Trump would be badly hurt so
he stayed out but Nikki Haley she's
Rising right now I think she's the only
one that has a shot of becoming the
nominee other than president Trump it's
a long shot on her part but she's the
one that has a shot so we'll
see notice what Romney says there at the
top he says I think Christie by
attacking Trump so hard he kept Trump
from showing up to the debates he's done
a great job now if you hate
Trump how could you possibly say that's
a a great
job that would be a great job well on to
Chris Christie had not showing up to the
debates hurt Trump but it hasn't if
anything it has helped Trump his numbers
have gone up since not showing up to the
debates so if you hate Trump wouldn't
you have to say Chris Christie he's the
worst because he if you really believe
Christie scared Trump away from the
debates which I don't but but if you did
think that wouldn't you have to say uh
darn it Chris Christie why why didn't
you shut up so we could have lured Trump
to the debate so we could have attacked
him more totally incoherent
but then Romney makes a good point he
says Nikki Haley probably has the best
shot of beating Trump and I think that's
basically
true not much of a shot but I think
that's basically true
because desantis's path to success is to
win over Trump voters which he has not
been able to do Nikki Haley doesn't
really need Trump voters Nikki Haley
much more naturally pulls from the
anti-trump
voters so if this gets down to a
two-person race
look maybe DeSantis could pull decent
numbers against Trump too but
Haley probably would more naturally
bring together the anti-trump forces
some of whom hate both Trump and
DeSantis to to pose a challenge to Trump
but what would that challenge be if
Trump is right now polling at 50% or 55%
or
more then that means that
Haley at best gets up to what like
30 maybe a little there's just the just
the numbers don't seem to be there
meanwhile speaking of candidates who
have been more in favor of
interventionism abroad uh Bernie Sanders
has a message for Joe Biden and a
message for Israel he's against all this
extra Aid that the US has been giving to
Israel I think when General Austin said
you can win the battle but lose the war
Israel is losing the war in terms of how
the world is looking at this situation
and I think that it would be
irresponsible for the United States to
give Netanyahu another1 billion dollar
to continue to wage this awful War I
mention
Bernie's attack on Israel
here really just because Bernie is a Jew
and every now and again people suggest
the Jews control the whole world all
just because they have the space lasers
they think they control the whole world
but I I point out this clip
because it shows you Jews just like most
groups but Jews in particular here are
not monolithic and in fact I would wager
that the state of Israel is more popular
among American evangelicals than it is
among Jews
broadly that uh when people blame the
Jews for this that or the other thing
uh they're they're just they're
forgetting all the really liberal
anti-israel kind of Jews they forget
that there are a lot of Divisions here
and perhaps they're just not even even
aware of it but uh Bernie Sanders does
not seem to be a huge friend or fan of
Israel right now even amid this war now
speaking of holy matters there's one
story I'm just going to tease and it
involves the voice of God Elon Musk just
came out he said vo the voice of the
people as the voice of God and he
reinstated Alex Jones on
Twitter
whoa that's pretty now and speaking of
these Twitter polls I took a Twitter
poll yesterday and I
said should I move to India and become a
professional sitar player and most
people said yes I
should so I I don't believe in the
principal Vox poly Vox day I believe Vox
deos Vox day but you've said it I will I
will abide by the results of that poll
so for the rest of this week at
least I don't know I'll give you updates
from social media in the meantime I'm
Michael nlls this is the Michael NS show
see you next
[Music]
time